this video is kindly sponsored by
curiosity stream
an online subscription streaming service
find out more
later in the video hey 42 here
sunrise is such a wonderful time to be
at the beach
the cool fresh air of dawn the lonely
cry of an early morning gull
the gentle crush of waves on the sand
the sea the sky the dead bodies
at least that was the kind of sunrise
that would have greeted you at summerton
beach on the 1st of december 1948
because it was on this day that the
quiet suburb of summerton
located just south of the city of
adelaide in south australia
gave birth to a profound mystery
that remains unsolved to this day
at about 6 30 in the morning local
police were contacted with the news that
a dead body had been discovered on the
beach
sadly this was not particularly unusual
at the time
the second world war had just finished
only a few years earlier
leaving many men struggling to deal with
the physical
and mental trauma of the conflict deaths
related to alcohol or suicide
were not uncommon but the man who was
found that morning
in 1948 had not been washed ashore after
falling off a pier
he was well dressed in a shirt and tie
brown trousers
socks and shoes a brown knitted pullover
and fashionable gray and brown
double-breasted jacket
his clothes were dry and his body was
resting upright against the sea wall
below the beachfront promenade
his legs were extended and his feet were
crossed
there was no sign of injury or assault
he looked like he died in his sleep
there was an
unlit cigarette lying on his shoulder
and his pockets were empty
except for an unused second-class rail
ticket
a bus ticket a comb some cigarettes
some matches and a half-eaten pack of
gum
but there was nothing that could be used
to identify him
he had no wallet and no id
and bizarrely all the labels
had been removed from his clothes if
you're enjoying learning about the
mystery of the summertime man
then i know you'll enjoy curiosity
stream
curiosity stream is netflix for nerds
hulu for history buffs the disney plus
for the scientist in us it offers
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals curiosity
stream is available worldwide and you
can find it on the web app
roku android xbox one smart tvs ios
chromecast
amazon fire amazon kindle and apple tv
you get the idea it's everywhere they
are continuously updating their content
and adding new and exciting titles
spanning science history nature
technology
society and lifestyle as you probably
know i
adore history and i'm absolutely loving
their enormous
high quality history selection one of my
favorites was how to build a castle
which follows a team of medieval
enthusiasts in france
who are building an actual castle in the
modern day
using only historically accurate
building techniques
i genuinely loved every minute of it so
if you're anything like me
and you love to learn new things then
you should check it out
you can have unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries
and non-fiction series if you head to
curiositystream.com forward slash 42
and use my promo code 42 to get 25
half which amounts to only 14.99
for the entire year check it out at
first glance there wasn't
anything remarkable about him he was
around six feet tall
had gingery hair and gray eyes and was
estimated to be in his early forties
he had broad shoulders and a narrow
waist and his hands and nails showed no
signs of manual labor
but the pathologist's report noted some
unusual characteristics
the unknown man's big and little toes
met in a wedge shape
like those of a dancer or someone who
wore boots with pointed toes
he was described as being in top
physical shape
and had pronounced high calf muscles
the kind usually seen on ballet dancers
or
people who regularly wore shoes with
high heels
he also had unusual ears and teeth
the upper hollows of his ears called the
simba
were larger than the lower hollows a
rare feature
found in only one or two percent of
people the summerton
man as he has come to be known also had
hyperdontia
a rare genetic disorder affecting only
two percent of the population
in which the lateral incisor teeth are
missing
and the canine teeth grow down next to
the front
teeth so overly developed high calf
muscles
unusually striking canine teeth and
large hollowed ears
i know what you're thinking vampire elf
cabaret dancer
like a mix of dracula liza minelli and
legolas
but police at the time didn't quite see
it that way
instead of asking around middle earth
they followed all the conventional
channels for identifying
a person searching dental records
trolling fingerprint databases scouring
international missing persons lists
nothing then in january 1949
a brown suitcase was discovered at
adelaide train station
it had been checked in the day before
the summertime man was found
and all its labels had been removed
the suitcase contained an odd mix of
personal effects
including a knife a pair of scissors a
stenciling brush
like those used by offices on ships to
stencil cargo
an electrician's screwdriver and a few
items of clothing with their labels
removed
except for free which were tagged with
the name
keane this wasn't much of a clue though
in the post-war period owning
second-hand clothes
was fairly common practice and police
were unable
to find anyone by the name keane missing
in any english-speaking country
they concluded that whoever had cut the
labels off all the other clothing
had either missed these three items or
more likely left the name on
deliberately to mislead investigators
in the suitcase was a card of orange
thread
made by a brand that couldn't be bought
in australia
exactly the same thread that had been
used to repair the trouser pocket
of the man on the beach for this and
numerous other reasons the police
believed the suitcase belonged to the
summerton man
piecing the evidence together
investigators thought
the man had arrived at adelaide train
station by overnight train from
melbourne
sydney or port augusta then he'd bathed
and
shaved at facilities nearby bought a
train ticket
to a town called henley which he never
used
and then traveled by bus to glenelg
the town nearest to where he was found
on the beach
despite all this evidence his identity
remained a total mystery in june of 1949
a public inquest was launched the
autopsy showed that the summertime man's
heart was in perfect condition
ruling out cardiac arrest as a cause of
death he also hadn't suffered from any
form of violence
instead he had internal bleeding in his
stomach and liver
and a massively enlarged spleen classic
signs
of poisoning even though no poison
was found in his blood at the inquest an
expert witness in physiology and
pharmacology
testified that there were poisons called
glucosides
the smallest dose of which could have
killed the man
whilst being almost impossible to detect
ultimately the covenant in charge of the
inquest was unable to guarantee the
cause of death
but he suggested that the mystery man
had been poisoned
and not by accident that was in july
1949 and it was around that time the
case started to get really interesting
whilst reprocessing evidence for the
inquest police found
a small tightly rolled up piece of paper
buried deep in a hidden pocket of the
man's trousers
on it was written the words to mom
should
taken from a famous poem called the
rubiat
by persian poet amar kyam the phrase
means
is over or is finished
a clear message from whoever had killed
the man
whether it be another person or himself
the ruby out was a popular poem at the
time
at the inquest one of the lead
detectives explained that the poem's
central message
was that whilst we're on the earth we
should enjoy life to the fullest
and when it's time for us to pass on
pass on
without regrets in case you're wondering
no i don't know if poetry is a subject
at police school
authorities began a public search for
the missing copy of the ruby hat
and eventually it was handed in to the
police around the time of the unknown
man's death the book had been thrown
through the open window of a car
parked nearby to summerton beach on the
last
page there was a gap where the words to
man
should had been torn out but the most
plot-thickening revelation of all
was when the police also discovered what
appeared to
be four lines of mysterious code
and another number that looked like a
phone number
the case took a radical new direction
this was the beginning of the cold war
and not far away from adelaide
scientists were building a rocket range
for nuclear missiles suddenly the
unidentified man with persian poetry in
his pocket
and a book with secret codes looked less
like a random fatality
and more like a character in a spy drama
after the code was published by a local
newspaper professional and
amateur code breakers alike tried their
hands at cracking it
but to this day nobody has been
successful the phone number on the other
hand yielded
more solid results police traced a
number to a local nurse
who lived about 400 metres from where
the summertime man's body was found
she claimed to know nothing about the
man but police asked her to come down to
the station regardless
and take a look at the plastic cast that
had been taken of his head and
chest when she saw the cast she almost
fainted and she was very distressed but
still
insisted that she didn't recognize the
man she then refused to answer
any more questions the police had run
out of leads
and despite the face of the unknown man
being shown in newspapers
across australia nobody came forward to
identify him
the cause of his death was also still a
mystery the medical examiner believes
he'd been poisoned but could neither
prove
nor disprove this theory claiming that
her reputation would be ruined if she
was connected to a case like this
the nurse asked that her name be
scratched from the investigation file
with no case for murder on the cards the
police had no choice
but to agree to her wish eventually the
taman shud case
as it was called back then turned cold
and faded from public interest then
in 2002 a seasoned detective by the name
of jerry feltes picked up on the case
feltus was nearing retirement and had
been moved to a different department
where he began working on cold cases as
a younger man he followed the case of
the summertime man closely and decided
to retrace the original investigation
by then 50 years had passed and much of
the original evidence had been lost
but with the help of derrick abbott an
academic from adelaide university
felters started to piece the case back
together
he managed to establish the identity of
the nurse
and tracked her to a new address her
name was joe thompson
and in the decades since the original
investigation
she'd moved more than 10 times
according to felthus every time the case
started attracting attention again
she'd go off on a trip or she'd move
house
when the detective asked her about
details of the case
thompson was evasive and kept changing
the subject
when he pressed further she started to
get so agitated
that he decided it wasn't worth causing
an old woman so much stress
and he left her in peace by now amateur
sleuth derrick abbott was getting a
little obsessive about the case and
totally weirding jerry felters out
abbott kept pestering feltus to tell him
the name of the nurse
but he refused eventually feltus
who by now had retired told abbott that
he was tired of what he called the
spanish inquisition
and that he was on his own he cut ties
and the men haven't spoken since this
didn't slow abbott down though
and he eventually discovered joe
thompson's identity for himself
he was two years too late though joe
thompson died in 2007.
to make matters worse in a 2013
interview with the investigative tv show
60 minutes thompson's daughter katie
said her mother had told her she knew
the identity of the unknown man
but would take it to the grave with her
thanks for nothing joe never want to be
deterred by minor hurdles like
death abbott persevered he knew that at
the time of the summertime man's
discovery
joe thompson had a one-year-old boy
named robin
by the time abbott was doing his
research robin had also passed away
but abbott managed to find numerous
images of him which he then compared to
photos of the summerton man
and noticed something quite striking
robin had the same incredibly rare ears
and teeth
which convinced abbott that robin was
the summerton man's
biological son the chance of the
summerton man
and robin sharing these physical
anomalies by coincidence
was between one in ten thousand and one
in twenty thousand
unable to raise robin from the dead
abbott did the next best thing
and tracked down robin's daughter who he
believed
held the key to confirming his theory he
took her out for a fancy meal where he
kept asking her
if he could take a look at her ears and
teeth before
casually suggesting he'd like to get his
hands on some of her dna
who says scientists aren't smooth
talkers perhaps more bizarre than
abbott's pickup lines though
is the fact that 24 hours later they
were engaged
by now abbott had spent more than 20
years trying to crack the summertime
case
and it looks like he might have finally
made a major breakthrough
after years of campaigning he's finally
managed to convince the south australia
attorney general
to approve the exhumation of the body or
at least what's left of it
so on the 19th of may 2021
the summertime man was dug up and
the process began to extract dna from
his remains
the forensic analysis could take years
and may not yield results at all
but this is the closest anyone has been
to closing one of the most mysterious
cold cases around
one possible answer is that the
summertime man was a british man
by the name of hc reynolds in 2011 a sea
man's identification card from 1918
was found which looks like it could be
the younger version of the unknown man
on the beach
a facial recognition specialist
maintains that they are
one and the same but there is as yet
nothing conclusive linking the two men
perhaps
dna testing will finally reveal all
but only time will tell thanks for
watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks